so now I'm just curious I wanted to
check in and see how you were doing
are you anxious to get back to work to
get back to the office you want to take
more time to know do you miss seeing me
every day see no do you know there is a
source stress at work he knocks food out
of my hands hey Conan oh hey so know
what's going on I'm just enjoying some
cookies we do have an HR guy on staff I
mean I could go get him right now do you
want to talk to our HR guy hold on a sec
no what's up
to make sure what happened my boss sucks
tell me what he did
quick he made fun of me he was talking
about making fun of me and snagging food
out of my hat me not food out of your
head yeah what kind of food like if I'm
eating cookies or a brown ear it sounds
funny sounds like a funny guy does like
a good guy I think he's a good guys boss
I gotta go gotta see him
how'd it go with HR this is the stuff I
miss you know what I'm on 5% battery you
knew that I was gonna be checking in on
you and you're only on 5% battery I am I
didn't plan accordingly you should write
a book called I didn't plan accordingly
the sternum obsession story cuz you
never plan accordingly or maybe I want
this zoo call to end so maybe I'll just
let him die no don't you go get the cord
and I promise to say nice things about
you while you're gone okay oh no it's
okay she knew that we were gonna have
this zoom call now she's wandering
around her house to try and find a cord
that should have been plugged in long
before this scheduled interview with her
employer oh hey how are you I think
having people about your brave journey
from Armenia to this country I would say
you're at home and so it's harder for
you to match your professionalism that
you have at work but nothing's changed
can you see me laughing at you
are you attack getting along well I know
you're newlyweds and you're still in the
honeymoon phase but some couples
experience friction I mean I thought the
biggest issue we had was he groomed our
dog himself and cut her hair too short
and now I'm a little upset about that
come here baby okay
he probably just looks too short to you
I'm sure it's fun Oh oh my god
[Applause]
[Music]
it looks like a dog at Chernobyl are you
cooking a lot I'm not baking as much but
you know I haven't had chocolate in a
really long time cuz I gave it up for
Lent I don't understand why people are
doing Lent to praise Jesus when Jesus
loosened this plague upon us Jesus did
this I don't know Jesus did this wasn't
it a bat
Jesus made the bat
the minute Jesus opened his robes and
loosened a plague upon the land I'm like
you know what no no no you don't get
your Lent this time around yeah I've
never seen you do legs I always do Lent
I give up things this year I gave up
giving you a hard time
well my favorite thing that you do
sometimes is when you're like you know
what I'm gonna be nice to you from now
on and it'll always last for about 30
seconds it's the longest you've ever
gone without being a complete dick come
on you can stop yourself from being a
dick for like 30 seconds and then it's
back to it back to the races back the
dick races you're a bunch of dicks on a
race track just like doing the worm damn
jockeys yeah well there are smaller
dicks riding bigger dicks and they're
doing the worm really faster on the
track and the guys going you're never
coming into work again are you no can
you at least pretend to hold a piece of
food and I can pretend to knock it out
of your hand
because I think this is a healthy thing
for both of us which you got there
these are biscuits and I'm so excited
I've been waiting a really long time to
eat
it's really nice talking to you I do
miss you I miss you too and you know if
we do go back to the office you you'll
be more professional you'll be more
grateful for the job you have because
you lived through a time when you
haven't had it
oh no the Internet's freaking up oh no I
can't hear you or see you anymore that's
too bad
son I'm obsessing everybody Thank You
Sona